[Music]  the PlayStation 4 has been killing it in  the sales department and now it sounds  like its marquee game is as well I'm  Matt and this is your uncharted gamespot  news update sony has announced that  uncharted 4 is sold through more than  8.7 million copies that number includes  both physical copies and units sold  digitally through the PlayStation Store  it's not explicitly mentioned but this  number likely includes uncharted 4 sales  through hardware bundles Naughty Dog's  action-packed adventure is included in  the main bundle for Sony's console which  likely helped boost to the game sales  Drake stays of treasure hunting may be  over with uncharted 4 but that doesn't  mean we won't get any more from the  series uncharted The Lost Legacy focuses  on series characters Chloe and Nadine  and it's expected to release on the ps4  this year for more news on uncharted and  the world of video games stay tuned to  gamespot  you